well it is 6:00 a.m. in Gaza where
Israel is bombarding The besieged
Enclave for a 16th day Israel's military
says it's stepping up attacks on the
Gaza Strip As It prepares for what it
calls the next stage of this war but now
there's also been a rare Israeli air
strike in the occupied West Bank at
least two people have been killed in the
Janine refugee camp when that strike hit
a mosque the Israeli Army says it's
targeted what it calls an underground
terrorist route it's believed to be only
the second time that Israel has launched
an air raid on the occupied West Bank
since 2006 well let's speak to our
correspondent sarak kyat she joins us
now from rala in the occupied West Bank
Sara as we've been saying an air strike
in the occupied West Bank is really
unusual what more do we know about what
happened
tonight yeah it is Nastasia and that's
why it took a lot of the residents of
refugee uh Camp by surprise in fact they
said they first heard it and then they
saw it they said that they'd seen an
Israeli fight Jet and that was later
confirmed by the Israeli Army saying
that it targeted this mosque because it
says it was specifically targeting a
place that was being used as a command
center if you like for uh Janine
Palestinian Fighters um that had planned
uh an attack uh coming up and that also
were behind several other attacks uh
from before on they said either Israeli
citizens or the Israeli uh Security
Forces now interestingly this particular
mosque was uh the uh Center of uh a
siege that happened back in July for 48
hours where 12 Palestinians were killed
homes had been destroyed at the time it
was a a massive uh raid on Janine
refugee camp the biggest uh since
2002 and during that time the Israeli
forces had um tried to destroyed tunnels
underneath the mosque that um they said
the Palestinian Fighters were using to
move around uh
undetected uh because of these raids
that Israel keeps carrying out on the
refugee camp um but they hadn't managed
to catch any of the fighters at the time
now they're saying that the uh
Palestinian Fighters which are part of
the Janine Brigade um were part of the
Islamic Jihad and Hamas just to give you
a bit of background on J the Janine
Brigade they were formed in 2021 uh one
of the biggest Palestinian resistance
groups here in occupied West Bank um and
they've been really uh a cause uh of of
concern to the israelies because they
are armed uh and they've been behind a
lot of the attacks that have been
carried out against their forces um and
they seem to be increasing in strength
uh year on year uh certainly this year
where there's been a lot of tensions
here Sor you mentioned raids there there
has been an intensified Crackdown there
over the last couple of weeks I believe
it's been more than a thousand people
now arrested is the expectation that
that will
continue absolutely not in fact just as
we're talking now there's been several
raids uh for the last couple of hours in
different areas here in occupied West
Bank near nais Bethlehem um just outside
of rala as well uh one of the
municipality uh U Mayors had has been
arrested too um so those are not going
anywhere if anything they're being
stepped up and of course one of the
biggest uh series of raids that happened
on Saturday into uh AC cross occupied
West Bank um they arrested more than a
hundred Palestinians they said mostly
the Israelis say mostly Hamas members
and um that's been verified by
Palestinians here so but apart from
those that they're targeting which is
Hamas members they've also been uh
arresting people that are posting uh you
know activists or journalists even that
are posting anything that's towards
support for those that are in Gaza of
course there's an assault by Israel a
war on people in Gaza and also we're
seeing that people are too scared if you
like to protest against that because
they're worried of those arrests there's
definitely uh a lot more fear amongst
Palestinians here of what's Yet to Come
sarak Kyra there with the latest for us
from rala in the occupied West Bank
thank you so much Zara